Things that shock me about the Dutch healthcare system
part I don't even know.
So today I went to do my blood work
and the doctor told me that after the results are out,
which is after 1 week,
I need to call them to get to know the results.
And I asked him,
no one is going to call me to tell me
what the results are.
He's like, no,
you have to call yourself.
Or if you have an appointment for something else,
you can come and ask the assistant.
They will tell you because it's in the system.
In my head I'm like,
so even if they find something
that I'm going to die in the next three days,
they're not going to tell me?
Even if they find this,
you know, dangerous diseases like hepatitis,
I don't know,
B or something,
this one that kills you in. In hours,
they don't want to call you and tell you,
so they just going to let you die.
Oh my God, now I see why people die just like that.